oh one of the joys of having people back
in the studio is right here i love it
nanny bobby our own cooking confidence
coach i love that concept i am so glad
you did and so many people ask about it
over and over what is it what does it
mean and so i thought i would take you
on a little adventure of how that works
i love it because
i don't have as much confidence okay
people like it so let's get you there so
on a scale of one to ten one being i
hate this i never want to do it in a
scale of 10 being like you feel great
you can cook anything you might just
want to learn more where do you fall
five five okay that's pretty good you do
some cooking at home i do okay so what
we want to do is we want to build your
confidence in the kitchen and we do that
by using your intuition and your
instincts and your creativity which is
an awesome thing so we've got this
recipe here which is a rice cauliflower
bowl and what we're going to do is we're
going to start with this rice
cauliflower this is organic rice
cauliflower that we started it's cooking
away and we're going to just use two
scoops of pesto now let me ask you this
how much pesto do you like just the
right amount okay but but what would you
like to put in um you know what about it
yeah i would probably say three
spoonfuls okay so that's too much nope
that's basically the whole thing so
let's do it let's put it in okay
now next is kale that's what the recipe
calls for but you can substitute whoops
let's not put the whole spoon in but you
can substitute kale with either spinach
right or you can substitute it with
something i brought which is sweet
potato leaves oh wow so this is right
out of my garden it tastes like spinach
but it's just a little bit sweeter so
what would you like to put in i know
kale is is very healthy but i do like
spinach better okay as far as the taste
goes so would you like to use both or
just one let's mix it let's yeah let's
mix both of them okay so here we go with
the kale there we go
and here we go with the spinach lots of
how about that a couple handfuls we're
going to
these will start to wilt which is really
great we may not have enough time for it
to completely wilt but look at that look
at how that's coming together can you
see that such a beautiful shot next is
sun-dried tomatoes okay okay so do you
love sun-dried okay how much let's do
the bowl the whole all right i'm liking
this okay now if we were to substitute
some dried tomatoes
what would you like like think of
something you would substitute it with
oh now
um
reese's peanut butter cups oh olives
maybe olives okay okay capers maybe yes
yeah papers maybe okay but my intuition
said candy but candy well i i don't know
that's for dessert how about that what's
your whole point here and i do like this
is that you know it doesn't have to be
really strict when you're
creating things in the kitchen right it
is about what you like what your taste
buds are right and this is what happens
is that i always say if you're if you've
got a big interview tomorrow you're
you've got a big presentation tomorrow
you should definitely cook the night
before why because it hones your
intuition and your instincts and your
confidence right also you're putting in
something that will not inflame your
body meaning you know you're not
allergic to it your stomach doesn't hurt
afterwards um and so what happens is
full circle you're learning to be more
confident in the kitchen
but your confidence here is a skill that
you take with you when you go to do
something big so let's add this is
starting to wilt really really nicely
how about some nuts are you good with
nuts i am okay
pistachio uh what are these ones pine
nuts pine nuts i love peppers throw them
in okay okay now next thing is we're
going to do your protein of choice which
is going to go right on top of this can
you see how beautiful that is what i
love about it is the green and the red i
mean it's just so fantastic so any
cooked protein now well how about a
little salt and pepper you throw the
salt and pepper in okay i'll step aside
there we go okay
you know and i cheat i have to tell you
this you know those home chef things or
yeah that's what i do well but see you
and why do you do it it's because you
don't really have the confidence
and if you did it you'd gain more
confidence and cooking should take time
that's what's most important here so
here's the last thing any cook protein
of choice okay so here is some pancetta
you eat pancetta yeah okay let's put
that in everybody'll eat that afterwards
okay and then we'll
mist it around how about shrimp let me
turn this off so it doesn't burn okay
how about some shrimp love it just any
cooked protein anything left over
chicken if you choose if you're
vegetarian or falafel okay tofu and
you're done and how long did that take
us not too long at all and it's all done
yeah so let me just tell you free offer
for your viewers at home go on to at
nannybubby on instagram go into the bio
link and you will find a free download
for the happy kitchen which is happy
spice cabinet or happy fridge learn how
to keep your fridge happy that'll keep
you cooking good and
that's it for today i love it check out
nanny bubby's kitchen and garden on
social media and online at
nannybubby.com on the count of three
let's do it spread love
we also want to thank chapman automotive
for sponsoring the segment we'll be
right back
[Music]